Michael smolens a founder of dotsub just
very quickly I appreciate the chance to
do when I see all of you using video as
an educational tool in some way it just
sort of cries out for me to show you
what we're doing here video that you're
all creating is in the original language
that's created mostly in this room
English we've created a very easy
browser based tool that enables
web-based captioning so this is a 47
minute video about Muhammad Yunus the
current Nobel Peace Prize winner was
made by a shoka and this is available in
these 75 languages acholi albanian
arabic azerbaijani etc and this was all
done by volunteers sitting at a computer
typing it in but let me just show you
the video that we were just talking
about that was the web is honest someone
just uploaded this video two weeks ago
RSS and plain English RSS is a very
difficult concept to understand this has
been in two weeks subtitled in these 12
languages so here's what the video looks
like in Arabic and you can scroll
through and see it in other languages
there is Ukrainian there is ty there is
Swedish its various Spanish etcetera
this is all embeddable on any website or
video blog and the amazing thing is in
two weeks without any involvement of our
organization this particular simple
video has been downloaded and is
rendered and embedded in over 200 global
video blogs and websites so what what
we're all about is the fact that i
personally started dotsub at age 56
because i believe that people need to be
able to communicate across cultures and
especially in the united states there's
no way the traditional media and
copyright will allow all of the great
stuff that's produced in other
which is of the world to be viewed in
our languages which to them is much more
important than ours you know people in
the other countries watching you know
desperate housewives are lost so this is
totally multilingual and to give you an
idea of how we're doing it if you have
created this video in the video is in
English so the original language in
English but and these are the languages
so if you just speak Arabic and you want
to translate this from arabic to
afrikaans you go hit translate and the
transcript is available in Arabic if
your language pairs arabic and Afrikaans
you don't need to speak any other
language and you can translate so we've
exponentially created the ability once
you go from language a the language be
then you can go from language be to any
other language and these videos are
fully viewable and embeddable and
scrollable across all languages and I
think for what you're doing from an
educational perspective it has you know
ramifications that we can't even think
about because no one has ever thought
about the possibility that something
like this exists so I just want to thank
you for sure that this we think i think
is something that if people understand
how it's used they can use it and just
so you know as long as there are no
commercial aspirations for the content
it is a free to use and free to embed
tool so okay thank you very much for the
time